el pib de dominica es uno de los más
débiles del mundo sin embargo en esta
pequeña isla de las antillas hay cada
vez más proyectos hoteleros de lujo
inaugurado en 2019 jong obey ofrece 120
villas escondidas entre las montañas con
una fabulosa vista al mar caribe
como pueden ver todo es muy natural se
conoce como un eco resort y el
propietario de lyon goodbye suele
describir como un verdadero jardín de
edad
en dominica todavía no hay un aeropuerto
internacional y la isla volcánica tiene
pocas playas de arena blanca pero para
atraer a los inversionistas este pequeño
estado ubicado en guadalupe y martinica
tiene un argumento de peso
invertir en jonglei le da a cada
inversionista el derecho a la ciudadanía
en dominica
la nacionalidad de dominica está a la
venta y es una de las más baratas del
mundo hay dos maneras de obtenerla una
donación de cien mil dólares a un
programa social en el país o una
inversión de mínimo doscientos mil
dólares en un proyecto turístico como
jon golpe y que ninguna trabaja como
intermediario en la venta de esos
pasaportes dorados la mayoría de sus
clientes no pisarán nunca a dominica lo
que los atrae está en otra parte
son personas que tienen nacionalidades
sujetas a estereotipos o dicho de otro
modo tienen dificultades para viajar no
pueden hacerlo por su ciudadanía actual
los clientes de king link son
principalmente de asia y de medio
oriente al comprar un pasaporte
dominiqués pueden entrar a más de 140
países en el mundo incluidos los del
espacio schengen con el objetivo de
tranquilizar a sus socios diplomáticos
dominica estableció una serie de
verificaciones para garantizar la
seriedad de los candidatos
los documentos solicitados incluyen una
ficha con información personal
formularios administrativos
cuestionarios y certificados médicos
[Música]
y extractos bancarios completos para
verificar el origen de los fondos
pero las verificaciones son efectuadas
por organismos privados que sólo emiten
recomendaciones a eeuu y la unión
europea les preocupa esa falta de
transparencia los programas de
ciudadanía por inversión pueden
facilitar la delincuencia financiera en
una resolución adoptada en marzo pasado
el parlamento europeo recomendó aumentar
la rigurosidad con los países que
ofrecen esos programas en caso de perder
el acceso al espacio schengen el
pasaporte dominiqués podría volverse
mucho menos atractivo
seguimos muy de cerca la situación y por
esa razón una parte de la comunicación y
el lobby lindo que hacemos con la unión
europea y eeuu es básicamente para
explicarles la importancia de sus
programas para nuestra economía
las ganancias del programa de ciudadanía
por inversión oficialmente representan
la mitad de los ingresos del gobierno a
través de las donaciones a los programas
sociales se obtiene un pasaporte por tan
solo 100 mil dólares con ese dinero se
construyen hospitales escuelas o
viviendas sociales como aquí en rojo la
capital
esta es la cocina y el comedor
es genial magnet foro la tecnología
moderna
coordinación' se mudó en abril pasado a
este apartamento totalmente nuevo
navidad en abril fue navidad en abril
gracias a este tipo de programas
sociales el partido en el poder cuenta
con el apoyo de la población como la
ciudadanía de dominica es un recurso
ilimitado el gobierno no repara en los
gastos
no hay alquiler no hay alquiler sólo
pagamos los servicios públicos los
fondos destinados al sector social del
programa de ciudadanía por inversión son
administrados por mms el esta empresa
privada ubicada en los emiratos árabes
desarrolla proyectos inmobiliarios para
el gobierno deberían haber visto la
inauguración las personas estaban tan
contentas lloraban literalmente lloraban
en total mmc administra más de 22 obras
incluido el futuro aeropuerto
internacional valorado en unos 350
millones de dólares esto representa una
gran parte de los contratos públicos
otorgados sin licitación
somos muy conocidos aquí y supongo que
la gente nos quiere a
este control de la empresa mmc es una de
las principales preocupaciones de la
oposición en dominica
el primer ministro nos dijo que el
dinero que estaba reuniendo para
construir viviendas sociales en dominica
no estaba en el presupuesto del estado
y
ese dinero está en un fondo de garantía
en el extranjero
oficialmente la venta de pasaportes ha
generado 1200 millones de dólares en
dominica entre 2017 y 2020 con base en
la cantidad de certificados de
naturalización entregados la oposición
hizo sus propios cálculos
hay 4.200 millones de dólares en la
venta de la ciudadanía dominique esa que
no está en el fondo público
estamos ante un caso flagrante de
malversación de un dinero que le
pertenece a domingo
el gobierno niega esas acusaciones y
aunque el jefe de la oposición apoya el
programa de ciudadanía por inversión
teme que esa falta de transparencia
afecte la reputación del país
es un asunto que le preocupa a los
gobiernos responsables del mundo no
puede haber países vendiendo pasaportes
que se conviertan en herramientas en
manos de delincuentes y que les permitan
viajar sin problemas a través de las
fronteras internacionales con los
privilegios concedidos por el
american awards
actualmente existen más de 100 programas
de ciudadanía o de residencia por
inversión a nivel mundial de los cuales
varios están en la costa caribe